- I really hope that people
also, if they read it,
realize this is not a book
that is meant to over coddle
the millennials or gen Z,
this is truly believing
that this is the alpha infrastructure
to building significantly
large successful businesses.
Hey!
You got your perspective.
(audience cheering)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
It is very clear to me,
25 years into my career
that kindness and empathy
and patience and humility
are actually the foundations.
And I think the things
that all of us think about
as soft skills and emotional intelligence
are actually the hard
skills that it is far easier
for me to find people
who are good at the task
or have good math skills
than it is to find people
who are capable of being the
bigger woman or bigger man
in the face of pressure or adversity.
And so for 20 years or so, this
has been in my subconscious.
COVID, like for many of us
gave me a time to reflect,
and I immediately went
into writing the book
on a couple of reasons.
One I'm incredibly aware that
there's a lot of young people
paying attention to my moves,
are fans, of what I do.
And I thought it would be a disservice
if I wasn't incredibly
aggressive in my communication
on the things that I see
as a winning formula,
it becomes double important
when I realize that most people
don't talk about kindness
as the single alpha skill
in building a successful empire.
And I thought it was a unique take.
It's also very nuanced.
The reason the subtitle is ingredients
is what I was going through, my process.
I realized, oh, I never
just deploy empathy.
I never just deploy patience.
In every situation
it's actually three or
four different traits,
often traits that are in a
conflict with each other.
It's very interesting to
be tenacious and ambitious
while being patient.
And so I liked the concept of ingredients
because it's like cooking a meal.
I think we all believe
that sweet and sour chicken
is something that is delicious,
but sweet and sour can see a conflict.
So I felt that I was the right
person at the right time.
And what has transpired
in the last 18 months,
'cause I wrote the book very quickly
in the beginning of COVID,
obviously takes time
for it to come out and
things of that nature,
many of us are thinking about
things in the business world,
around the concept of
the great resignation
and the concept of people even applying
into businesses in the first
place, in a world of options.
I think the importance of being a leader
that understands these
traits has even compounded
in the last 18 months
since I even wrote it,
which feels serendipitous
and exciting for me.
And I really hope that
people also, if they read it,
realize this is not a book
that is meant to over coddle
the millennials or gen Z,
this is truly believing that
this is the alpha infrastructure
to building significantly
large successful businesses.
- What I love is this
refreshing take on leadership.
And I can speak from a woman's perspective
that many of us have mimicked
this ideal hard leadership
because that was the architect.
That was what was the right leadership
and you're taking the narrative
into a different direction.
And so what would you say to those
who would point to titans
of industries and say,
well, this is not, how they were,
this is not what you're
describing the world.
- Look, I believe that you
can have short term success
in many ways and I believe that the world
has been very clear to us
over the last centuries
that fear and negativity
are sometimes a fuel
for short term success.
My argument is that it's not as powerful
as brightness and love, that
hate is a powerful trait,
but I just believe it never
beats love in the end.
And I believe that to be true in business,
of course there have been
people who've been successful
who are not kind leaders.
That doesn't mean that
it should be mimicked.
And I would also ask
if you have the luxury
of interacting with people in
their eighties and nineties
and especially those who've
had major financial success
by being mean and negative.
I think you'll find that
many 80, 90 year olds
who built their empire with darkness
have incredible levels of regret
and actually live quite unhappy lives.
And so my question simply
to business people is,
is the money worth the unhappiness.
- You talk a lot about
empathy and kindness.
And I think how many times
have we gone through
the last couple of years
with everything that's
happening in the world,
we need more kindness
and empathy than ever.
And the question here is how
do you deploy these attributes
without enabling that behavior, without?
- Well, I think first of all,
people want everybody else
to be kind and empathetic.
So my favorite part of this
book is accountability.
Everyone has become incredibly
good at judging others.
The world is addicted to pointing fingers.
I have never seen the world louder
about telling everybody
else what they're bad at.
So I think the way to deploy
successful kindness and empathy
is to actually start with yourself.
I also wanna remind everybody
that deploying kindness
when the other person
kind to you is very easy.
I challenge the world to
start having a conversation
with itself of does it have the ability
to be kind and empathetic
in the face of negativity?
My leaders are incredibly
kind to my employees
when everything's going well,
I don't need peace time generals.
I need leaders when
things are bad and hectic
to be able to be the
bigger woman and bigger man
in that situation to create a framework
of kindness and empathy.
So, you know, for me, it's
about the accountability
of being able to be that person.
Right now we are in a world
where everyone is so quick to
get triggered by bad behavior
that they fight fire with
fire which is why so little
is being accomplished
in society, in politics
and in the workforce.
And so for me, I think that we
are not spending enough time
with our thumbs and we
need to stop being addicted
to our fingers.
- Great.
One of the things you speak
about is self-awareness,
which is foundational
to any evolution for us
as human beings.
Tell us a bit about that and how do you,
where do we start with self-awareness?
- This is hard.
The concept of teaching
someone to be more self aware
is something I've been
thinking about for a long time.
You know, I think the thing
that drives so many of
us crazy in the world
is interacting with those that
struggle with self-awareness.
I think one of the hardest
things for people to deal with
is hypocrisy.
We struggle with it
and I struggle with it.
The exercise in the book
that I decided to do
was creating frameworks
for the people that know you
the best to create a safe space
for them to be able to tell you the truth.
I think one of the reasons people struggle
with self-awareness is
because they have enablers
around them that are allowing them
to get away with bad behavior.
And so I'm spending a lot of
time trying to think about
how one puts the people
that knows them the best
in a safe place to actually
give them the critical feedback
that could be the jar of a
journey towards self awareness.
It's a very tough challenge.
I don't know if I have the answer.
What I can tell you is no
question the business leaders
that I admire, the human
beings that I admire
are the ones who are off the
charts in self-awareness,
I'm incredibly grateful for
the luck of the DNA game
that I think gave me a lot of it.
I would argue that the only
reason I have any level
of popularity is because of self-awareness
because of the kind of communicator
I am and my personality,
I would be completely not palpable
if I didn't have high
levels of self-awareness
'cause I have some really funny attributes
as a communicator.
And so it's a conversation
we need more of.
I do think that self-awareness
has a very interesting
relationship with accountability.
I think that a lot of people actually know
what their shortcomings are,
but they try to navigate
the world in a way
where they are hoping
that people don't notice.
And it's something I'm
thinking a lot about.
- One of the things I
actually loved in the book
is the part where you talk
about relationship with time.
- Yes.
- And you hear often people
say it's too late for me
to start a new business, to
move my career, to be married,
whatever that may be.
So I'd love for you to
give us that perspective.
- The rules of the world right now
on when you should have
your life figured out,
when you should be married,
have children, make money,
buy a home and everything
else are based completely
on when people live to 45
and 55 years old, period,
the rules of our society have not changed
in a very long time of expectation
on what we should be doing with our lives.
The problem with that
is we're living to 100.
The concept that a 25 year old
should have everything
figured out is laughable.
Most 60 year olds I know don't
have their life figured out.
Why are 25 year olds put in such pressure?
I think that we have
societally done a very poor job
to our youth,
which gets me to a place that's
even more emotional for me,
which is we must challenge the notion
that so many parents in the
world use their kids' success
as their own self-esteem.
What that does is it pressures children
into short term behaviors
around education, occupation,
and relationships that are often missteps
based on very small windows of time.
One of the great reasons I struggle
with the way that education
is sold in our society
is we train kids from a very young age
that you will be judged every
90 days on your actions.
I think it leads to very,
very vulnerable behavior
that maps to our adulthood.
So yes, I think that way too many people
are judging themselves in the short term.
Yes I believe that if
you are 63 years old,
you still have 30 years
to achieve fulfillment and happiness.
And I think it's time
that we have a total different
conversation around age
to the point where in actuality,
the fact that we pressure children
into starting to get serious
at 22 is actually ludicrous.
22 to 30 should be wild, wild, high risk,
high reward behavior
because it's practical
because even if you blow
it and nothing goes well,
you can start getting serious at 30, 35.
And so we ask people to now
you're a grownup get a real job.
And all this other ludicrous behavior
that I think has really hurt society.
I think a lot of it is predicated
on outside affirmation.
I think many people start
doing things for validation
from strangers or their parents or others.
And I think we have to have
more thoughtful conversations
about it.
I think it's quite depressing
for lack of a better word,
that there are people
that are 40 years old,
still have 60 years ahead of
them and they think it's over.
I think that needs to stop.
- So one of the things that
surprised me in the book
is your health.
- Mm that's because Gary V
the guy that sits up here
is the king of candor.
- Exactly.
- I shoot it
straight as an arrow when
I'm talking to the world.
But when Gary Vaynerchuk the
executive is sitting across
from an employee that
he loves and he's scared
to tell her or him that
they're bad at their job
because he fears that that's
gonna put them into a spiral
of being scared that
they're about to be fired
is a lesson that has taken
me over 20 years to learn.
When I start started
really reflecting on why
in a world where I really
don't care about the money,
why would I have any employee
that has ever worked with me,
be unhappy with me?
And I had to look in
the mirror and realize
that the greatest shortcoming of my life
let alone my professional
career has been my inability
to be candorous about my
opinions and feelings,
which has led to subconscious
and then conscious resentment
towards that individual,
which has led to conflict,
which has led to me
randomly firing somebody
out of left field for them,
even though I thought they
should have known all along.
That was a very difficult thing
for me to come to grips with
because my greatest pride as a leader
is the elimination of fear.
When I realized that my lack of candor
was actually creating macro fear
because nobody actually knew
where they stood with me.
It was one of the darkest
days of my career,
but it was also one of the
greatest days of my career,
'cause it started the process
of me starting to figure it out
and me being vulnerable
and putting it in my book
for everyone to see,
especially when my reputation
as a content creator
is that is my strength
was an important step
in my own evolution.
- And what helped you actually
evolve that space like that?
- Reading Facebook groups
of former employees
that worked for me saying I was a jerk.
It's incredibly challenging for me.
I genuinely don't like money enough
to have people not like me.
I don't know what else to tell you.
It's a complete brain twist
for me that this could be.
And I finally had to
take on accountability
because it was very easy for
me to blame poor performers
because everybody around them
also thought they sucked.
So it was easy for me to justify,
like they were tone deaf.
They weren't self aware,
but the reality is I never
gave them a chance to fix it
because I wasn't willing
to give them constructive criticism.
And I, really so much of my strength
and so much of this book
is really just a story
of a boy who idolizes his mom,
but his mom also isn't great at candor.
And he picked up on that as well,
who also had a father who
was exceptional at candor.
But his delivery of that
candor was so terrible
that he demonized the candor
without realizing it was the vehicle
that the candor was being
delivered in that was the problem,
not the candor.
And so that was a process of
self-reflection and experience.
And for all the kids in here,
no matter how great you think you are.
And I thought I was super great at 22,
let me give you a preview.
The gray hairs come with some value.
- So on another attribute, optimism.
- Mm.
- So it's easy to be optimistic
when things are good,
when you face a hurdle or two,
but if your life is all you ever did,
if it's everything you ever learnt,
where do you draw optimism from?
- Well, this is where the
ingredients come into play.
My optimism comes from gratitude.
When you are grateful for what you have
versus envious for what you don't have.
Optimism comes second nature.
Life is always going to be challenging,
but perspective is something
we all need a lot more of.
We sit here today in this gorgeous room
while 850 million, almost 10% of the world
does not have access to clean water.
850 million people in this world
do not have access to clean water.
I have not been able to
put the pieces together
to be upset about a
business deal going awry
in a world where 850 million other people
don't have access to clean water.
I am dumbfounded by people's inability
to be grateful for what they have.
For me optimism is second nature
'cause I'm completely based
in fundamental gratitude and
I wish more people were too.
And that's why I like
talking about gratitude.
- Those attributes that
you're speaking about,
they're beautifully selected
and the way that we put
those ingredients together
actually are so practical in
terms of how broad is this book
to evolve and to kind of reflect.
- Can I jump in on that?
- Yes.
- It's incredibly important
especially for those in here
who don't have a lot of context on me.
I've been listening to the
first 10, 15 minutes of this.
Let there be no confusion I
am a full pledged operator.
I am only grounded in practicality.
For 22 of the last years
I have been responsible
to make payroll 100% on my own back.
Everything I'm talking about
right now is the framework
for those successes.
Yet I could be very empathetic
that somebody listening
right now may think
that this is a very optimistic,
delusional ideology.
That is why I wrote the book.
This is the furthest thing from delusion,
but society for over 100 years of business
have told all of you that
the things I'm talking about
almost have no place in business
or is a very nice to have
as long as you have all the other skills,
I promise you all those
other skills are a commodity.
The reason most businesses fail
is 'cause they're incapable
of firing the people that
are producing dollars,
but are destroying morale.
(audience applauding)
- Maybe one more question.
Before we take questions
from the audience.
Gary, with these attributes,
is this something that
actually we can work on
or are we capped at, whether
we're born with empathy or not?
- This is a great question.
I believe that we are born
with a lot of our traits.
I believe we are then parented.
And some of the traits go up and down.
I believe we are environments
of our neighborhood,
our country, our culture.
When I tell you the thing
that comes least natural
to me in the world is candor one on one.
And for me to see where I am
today as a 46 year old man,
everybody in this room has the ability
to grow in many of these attributes.
Most don't want to put in the work.
Most would prefer not to do the things
that come hard to them.
Most would hope that it goes unnoticed.
Nothing goes unnoticed.
People may not tell you,
but nothing goes unnoticed.
I believe in the human spirit,
the world is very black and
white to me on this one.
People evolve, people change,
people can get stronger at certain things.
People can get weaker at certain things.
And so I am incredibly
optimistic on humans' capacity
to evolve.
What it requires is first
acknowledging its truth.
Seeing it, one of the
reasons I produce the content
that I produce is with
the hopes that just,
when I do this right now,
literally when I tell you
that I'm just hopeful that
one person in this room
is listening and something triggers, one,
because that's profound.
Saying a couple of sentences
that shift a person's perspective
which allows them to start building
towards a better place for themselves
and the people they love is a great gift.
And I take on that responsibility.
And I think everybody in this room
who is fortunate enough
to be in a happy place,
has a requirement to
start communicating it
because we live in a world
today where negativity
is incredibly loud and
positivity tends to be silent.
And I think if you are positive,
you have an obligation to your fellow man
to communicate it and make it louder.
(audience applauding)
- Perhaps we take a few
questions from the audience?
- Yeah, these microphones
that are lined up here
excite me to no end.
I hope that tons of people,
I hope tons of people
or is that how we're doing it?
People are gonna come up to mics, please?
I mean, I see a lot of hands,
line up, there's a lot of mics
let's line up and do it.
Thank you.
- [Audience Member 1] Okay I used to be,
signed this couple of years
when I so vividly remember
that one day I was honest
about my company being compassionate,
where they came up to me and they're like,
you're supposed to do your job
when I was looking after someone,
that was the day I decided
that I didn't want to do this.
And I was looking at your
content all these days
and that was my trigger point.
And I decided to pursue
photography on the weekends
and now it's been four years
I've done that full time
freelance, I freaking love it.
And (indistinct) career in arts saved
and that was my savior.
And now I'm into NFTs
and I'm trying to bring
more people into this space.
I'm building a company in the NFT space.
What I'm trying to do is I
want get most of my friends
into this.
I feel like the NFT
economies, creator economies
is changing the world.
But I struggle with it and
I wanna know about this,
'cause you talk about
empathy and compassion.
And I regard myself as a
very compassionate person
so much so that sometimes
I want to help my friends
to get into the space.
And I'm unable to do that
'cause of their liabilities
and their responsibilities.
How do you, 'cause I know you
did say about general people
that you have the obligation
to explain to them,
but with your friends and families,
how do you come to terms
that you can't do so much
for everyone?
- Because I deploy patience,
everyone's on a different time schedule.
One of the great things that works for me
is a lack of expectations.
You know, I want everybody
that I ever talk to
to see what I see.
I'm also incredibly aware
that that is not going to
be the case on my timeline.
You've gotta realize that
even though you're coming
from a beautiful place,
the energy that you're talking
about right now is selfish.
You wanna feel the endorphin hit
of bringing value to somebody you love,
which is a wild concept to
realize that it's selfish,
all you can do is stay consistent
with your communication.
I mean, there are certain
things that I taught my father
that took me 26 years to accomplish.
If you love them, you
won't stop communicating.
- [Audience Member 1]
Awesome, thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
- [Audience Member 2] Hi
sorry, just a quick question.
You've been awesome
tonight Gary, thank you.
- [Audience Member 3] Gary you
speak about risks these days
but also awesome to see
your team all right.
- Thank you.
- [Audience Member 3]
Really help us keep up.
- Thank you.
- [Audience Member 3] And my
question is how do you combine
basically with about
the convenient operator
and contributing so much content
and the time to everything else?
- Thank you for saying that, couple ways.
One, I am very passionate
about giving back,
giving back comes in the
form of financial give back.
But ironically, I believe the
biggest way that I give back
is by being intellectually generous,
by putting out all my
content to the world for free
I'm bringing people value.
And so I compromise some
of my operational upside
on my selfish side because
I allocate more time
to put out content to the world.
Comma I'm incredibly operationally strong.
And I figured out many years
ago that if I just filmed
every moment of my life,
even though in the beginning,
it was gonna be very weird
that it was a more efficient
model for me to create content
that I could share to the world.
I am one of the most prolific
content creators in the world
and I never sit down and do content.
I just actually live my
life and it just built.
And so I think it comes from
the ambition to give back
and from being actually a good operator.
- [Audience Member 3] Thank you.
- Cheers.
- [Announcer] Who wants extra free books,
we have a ton of them.
- Extra free books.
Cheers.
- [Ben] Hi Gary.
- How are you?
- [Ben] Good thank you.
My name is Ben and I have
a silly question for you,
which triggers me lot.
Is it better to get in
your car and start driving
or knowing where to go?
- Hmm, that's a really fun question.
I believe the answer is very individual.
I believe if you're the kind of person
that has spent too much time
thinking about where to go,
that it's time to get in
the car and start driving.
I believe that if you're a
person that continues to drive
and you have no idea where you're going
then it's time to pull
over and give some thought
to think about where you're going.